all right guys we're coming at you with
another crazy analogy for something that
people really have the misconception of
when it comes to just myths and fitness
related things that we believe because
somebody said something and then I heard
Joe Schmo say it and now I believe it
all right so here's what we're talking
about today we're talking about soy milk
now I drink soy milk sorry boy I did
sort of buy into the myth that you know
soy was gonna affect my testosterone
level wasn't it might cause me to I
don't know make less muscle pains more
cloner Tiger Fitness calm [ __ ] tits and
soy I remember it hit like in 2004 a
crappy little web site decided to put
out an article on how soy increases
estrogen it might as well be taking a
girl's birth control pills solely boys
these pathetic beta males just look
house a week they are weaklings pathetic
absolute scumbags social and fit and
physical degenerates it's laughable but
it's not just laughable
it is also harmful soy boys are
reproducing they are creating beta males
from left to right causing the
destruction of Western civilization
needs to be stopped I am NOT even
memeing right now this is not meme
review this is a very serious topic of
discussion that needs to be brought up
don't believe the dangers of soy just
look at the soy Prince himself
Wil Wheaton glug glug glug glug glug
glug more soy milk bring me the bottle
and leave it
soy he's telling people to consume more
soy soy has estrogen in it so that means
if you consume soy you might as well be
a woman you know that right guy Aiko
mess mastiha manboobs that's right if
you consume soy you might as well flaunt
your we're a brine like a log if you
consume so you might as well put on a
bra right now and then wait for the man
boobs to come this is after in before a
soy do you understand virgin soy boy has
actual brain tumor that's right
soy costs us all kinds of this is not me
spreading misinformation this is just
proven scientific facts
it causes male breast cancer nowhere
hairy but on his feet karat cows moving
on to Chad perfect eyesight 20/20 he is
white like milk sorry boy is causing the
destruction of Western civilization the
dis D masculine say ssin of man has
caused all these pathetic beta males to
just multiply as an army they're taking
over what are we going to do but I'm
here to fight back finally someone that
dares to stand up against these issue of
the story just look at jacksepticeye
himself this is before and after soy by
the way absolute alpha from a pathetic
youtuber beta male disgusting I know it
hurts to see my friends become a victim
of soy but how can we spot a soy boy
feelings oh don't worry I will tell you
here's a high testosterone face very
defined ready to find a facial structure
just as mine of course I would say mine
is probably even a couple level of alpha
more than this man it's probably my
Viking Swedish genes and here you have a
classic the quintessential soy face
balding head or fully bald awkward beard
glasses and overly excited face I can't
I can't even I can't even recreate this
it is truly truly despicable stuff that
we're seeing here it's basically the
male version of duckface SOI boys just
can't help themselves they get too
excited about their Nintendo switch I
understand a video game console designed
for little children why wouldn't they be
excited about it what's next
they're gonna start building cardboard
oh they already do that oh look at PJ my
own friend suffering from shout out to
jacksepticeye for hooking me up with
this cardboard jack PJ who are they
gonna take next Brad oh it's already
happening I can't even tell them apart
from my own girlfriend these days do you
understand how hard this is they are
working together this is not just me
making some stuff up this is a real
conspiracy if you want to spot a SOI boy
just dangle a Nintendo switch controller
in front of them they'll start jumping
up and down excitedly immediately and
that's how you know you need to
euthanize them at the spot it is it is
our duty for mankind or our kind
sorry I don't want to discriminate
against women on this channel I had a
vasectomy yesterday and when I woke up
my wife's boyfriend surprised me with
how nice of the boyfriend there is just
too many examples for this to not be
fast you think I'm just making things it
writes itself
I came to open your eyes sheeple to the
soy boy conspiracy you want to know why
I didn't play God of War on my channel
because they might as well call it god
of soy why is he bald and have a beard
there's no way why do you think I even
shaved my baby so I just to to protect
myself from soy do you think this is
just made up huh they have been feeding
soy to kids since we were children
soy bean crea you ever wonder why saw it
the crayons are so delicious that's
because they've been feeding it to
children they've even created
purely soy-based meals called something
Soylent who just by the way sponsoring
this video thank you very much
Soylent I appreciate walking down the
street spot the Soylent truck now I'm
drinking sweet shy breakfast Jesse Cox
I'm worried about you I've already lost
PJ I've already lost Jack I've already
lost Brad one not Jessica what's next is
he gonna tweet about bear in front I am
gonna say it I hate bear at you taking
more two steps too far right now Soylent
is has turned people so weak they can't
even open the bottle themselves but it's
so easy I bench 350 and I cannot open a
goddamn bottle of Soylent well maybe
because you consume soy maybe
it's the courage to turning into a boy
I'm a man I find myself unable to open
the drink
maybe that's why everyone is just posing
with it instead of actually drinking it
because people just can't help
themselves posing with their Soylent
bottle nothing like a selfie with your
beverage wait isn't that isn't that the
host of bully hunters
how far does this conspiracy go yeah
look it says here sponsored by Soylent
but she tweeted very recently no soy she
tweeted no soy gringo corrado which is
Spanish for no more Soylent please it's
turning me into a deformed creature and
look at that
she lost her Soylent sponsor how far
this is Soylent conspiracy go you think
I'm just making this up who you think is
calling you a soy boy who is actually
calling you a soy boy don't listen to
this fake mean propaganda this is not
true the left side is always correct
okay for real no jokes aside it showed
that estrogen is in soy but it's not the
same estrogen that your body produces so
so consuming soy shouldn't actually have
any cause on your body or make you more
feminine or make you produce less sperm
that's all just less is all and I mean
that's despite a lot of control and I
feel like I have to be responsible here
and call it out so that people stop
using soy boy as some sort of insult
because it's not just mean it's also
extremely hurtful I just can't
understand why anyone would call someone
else a soy boy to prove that some fact
that just because there are lesser man
and enjoy watching someone else have sex
with their wife that somehow makes them
less I just we need to we need to reduce
this stage because it's all about the
onion that's right if you're not an
onion man and consume at least six raw
onions a day which is the only
scientific proven way to increase your
sperm count by the way huh don't believe
this year you heard about this onions
are the opposite of soy not even me me
you know who else like onions that's
right the most masculine man of mankind
Shrek
if you don't eat onion at least once a
day then you're part of the problem you
think I'm just making this up onions
head it keeps your heart healthy helps
you control diabetes improves immunity
lower stress have
check cancer keeps your stem healthy and
look at that a boost your sperm count
doesn't matter if you're a man or a man
you need to consume onions you may not
like it but this is what peak
performance look like onion man versus
soy boy okay that was a video hey of
course there's one way to very quickly
and effectively cure your soy boy and
it's by purchasing one of the sukkah
limited time only check out link in the
description to prove that you're a real
outfit that's right
I'm using memes to sell me merch got a
problem well you must be full of soy
[Music]